alors d'abord il ya une prise de
conscience de la fragilité du du
commerciaux navale
parce que l'accident qui a eu lieu la
semaine dernière
et bien cet accident des experts de la
circulation en aval n'avait cessé de
mettre en garde les différents
gouvernements contre ce risque
et puis donc il y à ce risque de
pollution ces bateaux il faut savoir
qu'un seul de ces bateaux consob disons
produit autant de pollution qu'un
million de voitures diesel aujourd'hui
alors oui je pense qu'il va falloir que
nous apprenions à réduire notre
dépendance vis-à-vis du commerce
international alors que le trafic
reprend dans le canal de suez
l'heure des comptes le porte-conteneurs
qui est bloquée pendant une semaine cet
axe maritime cruciale entre l'asie et
l'europe a mis en lumière la fragilité
du commerce mondial alors comment un tel
accident incident plutôt peut-il
engendré des milliards de dollars de
pertes que nous dit il de l'évolution du
commerce international c'est l'objet de
l'édito échos ce soir oui bonsoir
jacques sapir quelle histoire donc ce
bateau qui bloqua le canal de suez c'est
quand même plus fort que la sardine du
port de marseille je sais que c'était
une blague pour le 1er avril mais je la
lis quand même mon cher jacques oui tout
à fait bon soir stéphanie absolument pas
écouté oui c'était un très gros poisson
on peut lire un poisson qui est même
resté au travers de la gorge du commerce
mondial puisqu'il a bloqué à peu près de
12 % du trafic mondial
alors bon bien sûr le navire a été
dégagée au début de cette semaine mais
il faut quand même savoir que chaque
jour où il a été bloqué
ça a coûté aux armateurs l'équivalent de
8 milliards de dollars
autrement dit en trois jours un point de
croissance de la france c'est bien une
somme tout à fait extraordinaire et ça
prouve bien effectivement une certaine
forme de fragilité du commerce
international
essayer d'y voir plus clair jacques
c'est un peu plus sur ce qui s'est passé
oui tout à fait alors il semble bien que
ce navire et qui est un navire
d'ailleurs tout à fait moderne
il a été livré en 2018 ce navire a été
déséquilibré par une rafale de vent
extrêmement importante peut-être y at-il
eu une erreur humaine c'est ce que
disent les égyptiens
mais ce n'est pas confirmé et donc ce
navire est allé percuter la berge du
canal
alors il faut savoir que s'agit d'un
monstre des mers et on se rappelle
évidemment de cette image qui avait
beaucoup circulé
vous voyez une petit tractopelle qui
essayait de dégager ce navire il fait
400 mètres de long il jauge comme on dit
plus de deux cent mille tonneaux
autrement dit il est pratiquement deux
fois plus gros que le plus gros des
porte-avions nucléaire américain
actuellement en service et donc on était
bien là en présence d'un accident tout à
fait extraordinaire qui a bloqué cette
partie du canal qui se trouve entre port
saïd et ismaïlia autrement dit sur la
portion du canal qui n'a pas été encore
modernisée par le gouvernement égyptien
on sait que le gouvernement égyptien à
engager des travaux extrêmement
importants
il a agrandi le canal sur une portion
qui est plus au nord mais ils ne
l'avaient pas encore fait sur cette
portion là alors effectivement ça a été
un blocage d'environ six jours et sur
ses six jours et bien les armateurs ont
perdu 55 milliards de dollars
alors est ce que cela signifie que le
canal de suez reste la jugulaire de
l'économie mondiale non parce que il
faut aussi de voir le trafic qui passe
par le canal de suez a baissé en
proportion il a augmenté en volume
global mais il a baissé en proportion
et il ne représente plus à peu près que
12 à 13% après ce que ça montre c'est
qu'il y à bien toute une série de points
de passage qui sont des points de
passage obligé dans le commerce maritime
alors évidemment les deux grands canaux
le le canal de suez et le canal de
panama
mais il ya aussi des détroits des
détroits qui pourrait être bloqué par un
accident vous
par une volonté mal intentionnés de
puissance régionale et de ce point de
vue là si on connaît bien le détroit
d'ormuz l'asthme et avec tous les
problèmes qu'il ya eu autour de l'iran
on voit bien que à ce débouché du golfe
arabo persique et bien il ya une grosse
partie du trafic du pétrole et du gaz
mais il y a aussi et c'est un point
extrêmement important le détroit de
malacca par lequel passe aujourd'hui un
grosso modo 30 % du commerce mondial
or la question qu'on se peut se poser
chaque pourquoi le commerce maritime
mondial est il devenu si important est
ce que ce n'est pas le résultat de la
mondialisation
oui dans un certain sens oui c'est
absolument vrai et en fait on voit bien
que l'ampleur du commerce international
n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis 1971
jusqu'à grosso modo 2013 2014
alors on est passé de 15% à 30% après ce
qui est intéressant c'est que à partir
de 2013 2014
eh bien il ya une forme de stabilité et
sa peau bien aussi qu'il y a là un
espèce de ralentissement que grosso modo
est bien le commerce mondial n'augmente
plus maintenant ce qui est aussi
extrêmement important c'est le
déplacement du commerce mondial
vous savez au moyen âge et à la
renaissance
l'épicentre du commerce mondial c'était
la méditerranée puis à partir du xviie
jusqu'au xxème siècle ça a été lancée en
atlantique et depuis la fin du xxème
siècle et le début du 21e siècle et bien
les choses se passent essentiellement en
asie et ce commerce mondial est
essentiellement maritime c'est ça oui
tout à fait et là c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir que le volume du
commerce maritime
si on prend tous assis on prend à la
fois les liquides bon le pétrole les
pondéreux mais aussi tous les produits
qui circulent par bateau et bien ce
commerce a augmenté de plus de quatre
fois entre 1970 et 2010 neuf et désire
ce phénomène il ya une révolution une
révolution technique et technologique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
conteneurisation et avec la
conteneurisation effectivement il est
devenu assez simple à ces pratiques de
faire circuler toute une série de
produits par voie maritime et la
conteneurisation a beaucoup joué dans
cette expansion générale du commerce
maritime et le rôle joué par les porte
conteneurs a donc augmenté
oui tout à fait alors ça c'est si vous
laissez c'est quelque chose qui est
allée de pair évidemment avec cette
révolution alors sur tout ce qui est
très impressionnant c'est
l'accroissement de la taille des porte
containers en 1970 on était encore sur
des navires de taille moyenne à 27
milles tonnes de jauge brute ça fait
quand même je vous signale un assez gros
bateau bon on avait vu cela se
multiplier par 2 en 1902 1970 5 à 90
l'union encore par deux de 1990 à 2005
et on aboutit aujourd'hui à un monstre
comme les verts given qui est donc qui
était la cause du problème dans le canal
de suez ce qu'on appelle la classe
golden qui lui fait environ 220 milles
tonneaux de jauge brute alors évidemment
ces navires sont donc de plus en plus
gros
de plus en plus puissants et donc de
plus en plus polluants pourquoi parce
que leur machinerie consomme presque
exclusivement de ce qu'on appelle du
fioul lourd autrement dit des résidus de
pétrole
ces résidus de pétrole sont très
dommageable en termes de particules
fines et en termes de co2 et il y avait
énormément de bateaux on considère qu'il
y a grosso modo 6000 porte containers en
service dans le monde
sur ces six mille il y en a probablement
12 cents à présent qu'ils sont de très
gros porte conteneurs d'aidé des porte
containers géant
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien ça
veut dire que ce sont des bateaux qui
consomment beaucoup beaucoup de pétrole
a pratiquement 300 millions de tonnes et
si ces bateaux était un pays c'est la
scission ont décidé que leur
consommation de pétrole était celle d'un
pays et y ait une serait le sixième pays
du monde pour les rejets de gaz
polluants
alors jacques à quelles seraient les
solutions possibles dans ce cas alors
oui il ya plusieurs types de solutions
une première solution qui est déjà
qu'ils commencent déjà à être mise en
oeuvre en particulier par la cgm la
compagnie d'armement française est bien
c'est de faire basculer les machineries
de ces énormes navires du fioul lourd
vers le gaz naturel liquéfié la cgm a
mis en service depuis deux trois ans
plusieurs navires qui fonctionne au gnl
comme on dit et c'est effectivement
moins polluants après l'autre principale
solution pour diminuer cette pollution
c'est de réduire le trafic est peut-être
d'utiliser d'autres voies ou d'autres
moyens de ce trafic
alors la russie qui évidemment a profité
de ce qui s'est passé sur le canal de
suez pour des vous savez nous nous avons
la route maritime du nord qui
permettrait d'aller plus vite de
l'europe vers l'asie bien mais est ce qu
elle fait surtout avec la chine c'est de
développer désormais ce qu'on appelle la
voie à grande vitesse du transsibérien
il s'agit pas des 300 km heure comme le
tgv en france mais ça signifierait quand
même plus du doublement de la vitesse de
circulation des convois et donc des
marchandises des containers qui serait
chargée sur la côte sud de la chine
pourrait arriver au coeur de l'europe à
la frontière entre le bélarus et la
pologne en sept à huit jours
c'est grosso modo moitié moins de temps
que ce qu'il faut pour les transporter
par container et donc on pourrait
décider de décaler tout le trafic de
choses relativement urgente par cette
voie et ne garder finalement le trafic
navale que pour les marchandises très
lourde et pour lesquelles on peut
prendre son temps comme par exemple les
minerais ou le pétrole mais jacques
maintenant que le canal de suez et
débloquer tout va pouvoir recommencer
comme avant n'est ce pas alors tout va
pouvoir recommencer comme avant
je crois qu'il ya quand même eu une
prise de conscience alors d'abord il ya
une prise de conscience de la fragilité
et indus du commerce au naval parce que
l'accident qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière
et bien cet accident des experts de la
circulation en aval n'avait cessé de
mettre en garde les différents
gouvernements contre ce risque
et puis donc il y à ce risque de
pollution ces bateaux il faut savoir
qu'un seul de ces bateaux consomme 10
ont produit autant de pollution qu'un
million de voitures diesel aujourd'hui
et je le rappelle il y à plus de 1000 ou
de doute ce en suivant les sources
bateau énorme qui circulent
autrement dit on est sur une quantité de
pollution qui est très supérieure à
celle de la circulation automobile alors
oui je pense qu'il va falloir que nous
apprenions à réduire notre dépendance
vis-à-vis du commerce international pas
de ces commerces est bien entendu mais
de réduire notre dépendance et de
produire peut-être des choses plus local
ou plus régionale est en tous les cas de
réduire notre dépendance par rapport aux
transforma rythme à longue distance